RONALD SMITH: Well, today I'm
going to finish up a two-lecture
description of paleoclimatology
and the ice
ages, and then starting on
Friday, I'll go into the
subject of global warming.
And I'll be lecturing about that
Friday, next Monday, and
then you have your exam.
I may even be continuing
that subject on
the following Friday.
So we're going to spend about
a week on global warming.
And it's a very controversial
subject, very interesting
scientifically, politically,
socially.
And we've laid a good foundation
for studying it.
All the things we've studied
up until this moment,
including this stuff, I think
will help us as we try to
struggle with this issue
of global warming.
So any questions there?
If not, so you remember, we
started this last time.
And I'm just going to flick
through so these are the
subjects we're doing.
And I did these first
three last time.
Today we're going to finish up
the remaining four subjects
within this general area.
So just to flash everything
by you.
We talked about the last
glacial maximum.
We got here.
So let me put a couple things
up on the board just to
reinforce what's here.
Hydrogen has a nucleus with one
proton, therefore it has a
single positive charge and
typically has one electron
with a negative charge
going around it.
There are two famous isotopes
of hydrogen.
One is deuterium, and
one is tritium.
I'm not going to talk about
tritium today, but I'm going
to talk about deuterium.
It has one proton
and one neutron.
This has a mass of one.
This has a mass of two.
But notice it still has just one
positive charge, so it has
just one electron
going around it.
So chemically, the two
are identical.
They have the same electronic
orbitals, and they'll bond and
so on in just the way--in
the same way that
the other one does.
The other one I want to
think about is oxygen.
Oxygen typically has eight
protons and eight neutrons.
Because of eight protons, it
has eight positive charges.
It'll have eight electrons
going around it.
And that will determine its
chemical properties.
And this would be called
oxygen 16.
Sorry.
Oxygen 16, because that
mass adds up to
16 atomic mass units.
The other one we're interested
in has 8 protons and 10
neutrons, adding up
to a mass of 18.
Still has eight protons,
therefore has eight electrons.
Same chemical properties, but a
different mass, and this one
is called oxygen 18.
And by convention, that mass
number is put to the upper
left of the letter symbol
for that element.
So oxygen 16 and oxygen 18.
Now, we're interested
in water.
So the question is what water
molecules can we make from
these isotopes?
And by far the most common would
be normal H2O, which
would have oxygen 16 plus two
hydrogens coming off it.
Water vapor has a
dihedral shape.
It's not a linear molecule.
The hydrogens droop off
it at an angle.
That's by far the most common,
because this is much more
common than that by a factor
of 1,000 or so.
And this is much more common
than that by a
factor of 1,000 or so.
So if you just randomly put
these molecules--these atoms
together to form molecules,
almost everything is going to
be like this, but there are
going to be some that have
this structure where you replace
one of the hydrogens
with a deuterium.
Notice that this has a mass
of 18, because it's
16 plus 1 plus 1.
This is going to have a mass
of 19, because it's
16 plus 2 plus 1.
And then the other one is where
you replace the oxygen
16 with oxygen 18 but keep both
of these as hydrogens.
That's going to be 18, 19, 20.
So that's going to have
a mass of 20.
Now you can imagine others.
For example, you could replace
both of the hydrogens with
deuterium, but that would
be so rare that I'm not
interested in it.
Or you could replace the oxygen
16 by 18 and one of the
hydrogens by deuterium, but
again, that is so rare that
I'm not interested in it.
So I'm going to just
limit myself
to these three isotopes.
This would be called the normal,
and these would be the
heavier ones.
And we keep track
of the ratio.
For example, if you're comparing
these in a sample,
you would measure
the D/H ratio.
Or if you're comparing these
two, you would take the ratio
of oxygen 18 to oxygen 16.
And the higher this is, you
would say--the common
terminology is that the water
is heavy if it has a large
deuterium to hydrogen ratio,
or it's heavy if it has a
large oxygen 18 to oxygen 16
ratio, or light if it's got a
lower than usual ratio
of deuterium.
So I'm going to be using these
terms heavy and light in a
relative fashion to describe
whether these ratios are
typical for ocean water or
larger or smaller than that.
So I hope you've Googled or gone
back to your high school
or college chemistry book
and reviewed this.
Now, isotopes also appear some
isotopes are so-called
radiogenic isotopes.
They are temporary isotopes that
can be formed by nuclear
reaction and then decay
automatically
with some half life.
Those are called unstable,
or radiogenic, isotopes.
And maybe those are the isotopes
you've heard about
before, but I'm not talking
about those.
These are called stable
isotopes, because they remain.
They don't have any
natural decay.
They just exist in these
different mass forms, and they
persist over millions and
billions of years.
So these are the stable
isotopes--in this case, I
would call these the stable
isotopes of water, which is
what I've labeled this slide.
Any questions on that?
So now for our purposes, it's
very important to know that
the heavier isotopes, these
two, have a slightly lower
vapor pressure.
Because they're heavier, they
move a little more slowly in
the liquid, which means they
evaporate more slowly than
this, but they would
condense more
readily than normal water.
Therefore, when you do get a
phase change, when you get
vapor going to liquid or you
get liquid going to vapor,
there will be a fractionation.
This is the other new word.
A fractionation means a process
where you change the
ratios of these two things.
For example, if you had a bucket
of nuts in your room
peanuts and cashews and your
roommate happened to be a
cashew lover, so when she was
grabbing a fistful of nuts,
she would tend to get one that
had more cashews in it, that's
a fractionation process.
What's being left behind then
is going to be a little bit
heavier, a little more enriched
in the peanuts and a
little bit more depleted in
the cashews, because she's
grabbing out her
favorite nuts.
That's what's going on when
you're evaporating or
condensing water.
You're changing the ratio of
peanuts to cashews by the way
you're doing that thermodynamic
transformation,
vapor to liquid or liquid
back to vapor.
That's what we're going
to be tracking today.
Now, the way we keep track of
these ratios is with the
so-called called
delta notation.
We have to define a reference
ratio of D/H. And that's
standard mean ocean water.
It's basically a sample
of several
places around the ocean.
They collect, mix them all
together, and store large
volumes of it in laboratories,
and use that as a reference
every time they're doing an
isotope ratio measurement.
So that's called--the
abbreviation for that is SMOW,
standard mean ocean water.
Then you measure the D/H ratio
in the sample of interest,
divide it by the D/H ratio in
your reference liquid, SMOW,
subtract 1, multiply by 1,000,
and that is so-called the
delta D value.
If it's deuterium, it's delta
D. If you do the same thing
with oxygen, it's the
delta O-18 value.
And that's what we'll
be tracking.
So notice the way this
is subtracted.
So if you had a sample that had
a larger ratio of D/H than
the reference, that would end
up being a positive number.
And we would call that--
we'd say the sample is
heavier than SMOW.
If the D/H ratio is less than
the standard, then the number
is going to turn out to be
negative, and we're going to
say that sample is lighter
than SMOW.
This quantity is usually stated
as per mill or written
not with a percent sign but with
a percent sign with two
zeros on the bottom.
So again, a reservoir of liquid
water under evaporation
will become isotopically heavier
because the lighter
isotopes will evaporate
more readily.
A reservoir of water vapor
imagine some water vapor in
this room, and we're condensing
out some of it
that's going to be isotopically
heavier--sorry,
lighter, because the heavier
isotopes are condensing out
and leaving preferentially.
You can do these experiments
in the laboratory.
You could take a
dish of water.
Take a sample from it.
Put it into a mass spectrometer
to determine the
isotope ratios.
Then let it sit there
for a few days
and partially evaporate.
And when you came back and took
another sample of the
liquid that would be this case
and again put it on the mass
spectrometer to get the isotope
ratio, it would be
heavier--isotopically heavier,
because the lighter isotopes
would have evaporated
preferentially.
So it's an easy thing to do in
the laboratory to measure this
physical process called
isotope fractionation.
Now, in the real world, if you
start with an ocean value of
zero, the delta D value, or the
delta O-18 value would be
zero, which is likely, right,
because ocean is our modern
reference for isotope ratio.
So typically, the delta values
for modern ocean are going to
be very close to zero.
When you evaporate, the
isotopes--the lighter isotopes
evaporate preferentially, and
so the vapor you have in the
atmosphere is typically going to
be lighter than the ocean.
It will have a negative
delta value.
And then as you condense water
out, the rain is going to be
heavier than the vapor.
So if the vapor is minus 10,
the rain is going to be
heavier than that.
Let's say minus 3.
The remaining vapor after you've
removed some of the
liquid is going to be lighter
still, because you've removed
some of the heavier isotopes.
Then if you rain again from
that lighter vapor, the
precipitation is going to be
heavier than that vapor but
lighter than the rain that
fell out before.
And the vapor remaining is
going to be even lighter,
because you've removed heavier
isotopes of the vapor that you
started with.
So this is the progressive
fractionation process.
This is a little bit tricky.
So if there's questions here,
let me go back over this.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR:
I'm sorry?
STUDENT: What does the negative
hydrogen mean?
PROFESSOR: So that's
the delta value.
That would be--iff that's delta
O-18 and I think those
values would be appropriate that
would be the value here.
And if it's negative, it means
that that number was less than
that number.
So that ratio was less than one
so that when I subtracted
one from it, I got a
negative number.
So what it's telling me is that
that sample is lighter
than my ocean reference,
my SMOW reference.
So all the numbers in this
cartoon are delta values, and
they're indicated that by that
little per mill sign there,
that per thousand sign there.
That means not per
hundred like a
percent, but per thousand.
Question.
STUDENT: So it's compared to
SMOW water sample that came
from the ocean?
PROFESSOR:
That's right.
That's why this first value is
zero, because it's being
compared with ocean.
And so that delta value turns
out to be zero if it is ocean
water you are sampling.
STUDENT: So what's the
difference between the rain
and the precipitation?
Why is one lighter
than the other?
PROFESSOR: Well, the
rain--this is the rain.
I hope I didn't misspeak.
Rain and precipitation I'm
using synonymously.
But I'm drawing a stark
contrast between the
vapor and the rain.
So here the vapor you're
starting with is
minus 10 per mill.
The rain that comes out of that,
while it's lighter than
ocean, it's heavier than the
vapor from which it's formed.
So it has a negative number, but
not as negative as that,
making the vapor still lighter,
making the next
precipitation still lighter.
And the vapor is even lighter
than that vapor.
So the things progress along
together, gradually raining
out the heavier isotopes.
Yes.
STUDENT: Why are
evapotranspiration and the
vapor--the second
vapor--different numbers?
PROFESSOR: I'd rather
not talk about this
one, because it involves a
complicated process of what
water has fallen to Earth and
what is being re-evaporated.
So let me just ignore that.
This is a correct value on
average, but I'd rather not
get into that, because it
complicates the picture.
We're just going to deal with
primarily these issues here.
Yes.
STUDENT: Does the percentage
of the vapor as it gets
increasingly smaller, or more
negative, how does that affect
the weather?
PROFESSOR:
Not at all.
This is a climate diagnostic
subject.
It has nothing to do it all with
how the atmosphere works.
That's the thing about
these isotopes.
They're behaving chemically like
ordinary elements, and
this slight shift in the vapor
pressure is so small that it
doesn't have any
known influence
on the weather patterns.
So we're just using this as a
tool to understand what nature
is doing, not as something
that will change nature.
So when you take a--when you go
to Antarctica or Greenland
and dig down and pull out an
ice core, you're going to
get--you're going to look at
things as a function of depth.
I'll show you some pictures
in just a minute.
But from that ice core, you're
going to shave off ice from
different depths and determine
the delta D and the delta O-18
values as a function of depth.
Generally, the isotopes
in the ice cores are
lighter than the ocean.
We saw that, because for
example, the precipitation
falling on this mountaintop
is lighter than the ocean.
It goes back to this initial
evaporation.
The vapor became so much lighter
as it evaporated that
that lightness still remains,
is even amplified by
precipitation that's occurred
between the ocean and the
location where you're
getting your sample.
So the isotopes in the ice core
will be lighter than the
ocean, but they're not
going to be constant.
They're going to vary
with climate.
And in the literature, there are
two ideas that have been
put forward to understand
why those isotopes
would vary with climate.
One is that under a different
climate situation, the source
of the water vapor
might change.
Something back here
And the other is that the
fractionation that takes place
in the atmosphere between the
ocean and your sampling
location might change.
So I put that here.
Source changes or changes in
that progressive fractionation
in the atmosphere.
It's believed now by almost
every author that this is the
dominant one.
So I'm going to focus on this.
So in the next bullet, I said
it's mostly sensitive to local
air temperature, as that
measures the degree of
fractionation, which means that
you get a light isotope
signature during ice age.
I've tried to illustrate
that here.
So you have some water
vapor source.
We're going to presume for the
moment this is constant,
giving you the same
isotope ratios in
the evaporating vapor.
Then as this air parcel moves
along and encounters different
clouds and different storm
events, you're going to
gradually precipitate
out that water.
Every time you do so, you're
going to be precipitating the
heavier vapor, leaving
the lighter behind.
So the next precipitation is
going to be lighter than the
first and still lighter
and still lighter.
And so the isotope ratio in this
final falling snow that's
going to fall on your ice sheet
is going to depend on
how much you've cooled the air
between the source and the
sample area, because the more
you've cooled it, the more
water vapor you have removed.
Remember, when you drop the
temperature, you decrease the
amount of vapor that
can be held.
And therefore, if you cool the
air a lot, you've had to
remove more and more
of the water vapor.
And when you do that, you get an
isotope which gets lighter
and lighter in proportion to how
much you've cooled the air
going from source to
record location.
All right.
So we're going to look at
some Greenland cores.
There have been a number
of them done.
Camp Century, a couple
of GRIPs, GISPs,
GISP 2, and Dye 3.
Here's a snowfall map
of Greenland.
Most of the accumulation is down
here in the southeast,
but you get some accumulation
everywhere.
And what we're going to do is
to put a drilling rig up on
the ice cap, up on the ice
sheet and drill down.
Here's a scientist marking
an ice core.
And ice core is about
that big around.
And it can be many hundreds
of meters, even a
kilometer or so deep.
And of course, they pull
it out in sections.
They pull out a section break
it, lay it down, put it in a
storage shed, then drill out
another ice core and so on.
So they end up with these things
stored in sections, and
then they can do analysis
as a function of depth.
And if they have some kind of
a dating tool, they can
determine what age that ice is
at, of course older and older
as you go deeper down
into the ice core.
We've done this on Antarctica
as well.
All these dots are places
where there
have been ice cores.
We're going to be talking about
the Vostok Core, which
is one of the deepest cores.
This one was done by the
Russians some years ago.
So here's a record then
with years before
present on the x-axis.
And in the upper panel are
cores from Antarctica.
And they are represented
as delta D values.
Here they've written
it as delta 2H.
Remember 2H is what we're
calling deuterium.
So this is the same as
our delta D value.
And then down in the lower panel
is the delta O-18 for a
Greenland ice core in fact two
of them, NGRIP and GRIP.
And you can use either
isotope.
It doesn't really matter which
pair you're using.
You get a similar signal
for climate change.
There isn't a great deal of
difference between using delta
D and delta O-18 for
these purposes.
But the numbers are different.
For example, for delta D, the
delta values are much larger.
They're minus 460, 440, 420,
whereas for oxygen, which
fractionates less strongly,
you get somewhat smaller.
Notice that they're all negative
though, which means
that all these ice samples
are isotopically
lighter than the ocean.
We expected that for
two reasons.
One is the water that evaporated
from the ocean was
lighter than the ocean water
itself because of
fractionation.
And then this path fractionation
as the water
moved from source to Antarctica
or source to
Greenland, you've made it even
lighter by raining out a
fraction of the water
on the way to this
final record location.
Well, this gives us a rather
nice time record.
This is the modern era.
This is today, if you like and
it looks like we have somewhat
heavier isotopes than normal
during the last 12,000,
15,000, 20,000 years ago.
And of course, this is the
Holocene Period, the last
interglacial.
Prior to that, the isotope
ratios were more negative,
which means lighter.
And we would interpret
that--according to the
dominant literature on this--we
would interpret that
as having more water removed
between source and sample
location, which means
a lower temperature
at the sample location.
So the conventional wisdom is
to interpret this as giving
you a temperature record near
the place where the record is
kept, near the ice sheet.
So colder.
Staying cold for about
100,000 years.
Then a brief interglacial, and
then back into another long
ice age with cold conditions
at least at the location of
the ice sheet.
May be cold other places as
well, but what we're measuring
here, we think, is the
temperature of the air over
the ice sheet where those
snowflakes are being formed.
This is Antarctica.
And notice that both cores done
independently show a very
similar record.
Even more surprising is that
when you go to the northern
hemisphere in Greenland, you get
a record that, again, is
fairly similar with
interglacials, glacial
periods, the Holocene.
So this seems, although it's a
local measurement, it seems to
be global in character.
And this is a characteristic
then of global climate, even
though it's a local temperature
record.
Questions on this?
I still find this astounding
that these different ice cores
from different hemispheres give
such similar records.
Yeah, Jordan
STUDENT: Can you explain again
why the lighter isotopes means
colder temperatures?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
because in this model, let's
say this is at a fixed
temperature here.
And so if you just cool the
air a little bit between
source and ice sheet, you would
remove maybe half the
water vapor and fractionate
it accordingly.
But if this were much colder,
you would remove a much larger
fraction, maybe three quarters
of the water vapor, that would
fractionate more strongly, and
you'd get lighter isotopes
falling on the ice sheet.
So temperature, remember,
controls how much water vapor
you have in the atmosphere.
So the more cooling you
get, the more water
vapor has to be removed.
The more water vapor you remove,
the more fractionation
there's been in the
isotope ratio.
OK.
So it's remarkable that these
two local records of
fractionation and temperature
are so similar.
They provide an accurate time
record of the ice ages.
One more thing that's even more
astounding, you can take
those same ice cores and find
tiny bubbles in them.
As the snow fell and more snow
fell on top, and you finally
compacted it into ice, there are
little bubbles that trap
samples of the ancient
atmosphere.
You can stick a probe into those
ice bubbles and do a
carbon dioxide concentration
analysis to find out what the
was in those ancient
atmospheres.
So here I've plotted up from
the Vostok Core alone, a
record that goes the time
axis is switched here.
This is today, and this
is going back in time.
This goes back a bit further.
I've shown you data back
to 400,000 years ago.
Here's the isotope record
converted to a temperature.
Isotope record converted to
an equivalent temperature.
And then in the top panel
is the carbon dioxide
concentration taken from
the same location
along the ice core.
Here's the modern day.
At the top of the ice core, you
had about 280 parts per
million by volume, which is
about the value we think is
the pre-industrial carbon
dioxide value for the Earth's
atmosphere.
Then back in the end of the last
ice age, the last glacial
maximum is here.
You had much lower carbon
dioxide concentrations, even
below 200 parts per thousand.
It stayed low, and others have
mirrored the temperatures
quite remarkably.
Carbon dioxide concentration
and
temperature are very similar.
They have a very similar record,
at least over this
period we call the Pleistocene,
with the ice ages
coming and going and
coming and going.
We'll talk a lot about this
coming up in the global
warming, but at a very minimum,
this reinforces our
idea of the importance
of CO2 and climate.
When you had high CO2, you
had warmer climates.
When you had low CO2, you had
colder climates, perfectly
fitting with our idea of the
greenhouse effect and CO2
being a greenhouse gas.
Now there's also some argument
though about cause and effect,
which comes first, which
leads and lags.
We'll get into that a little
bit next week.
But for the time being, I would
take this at face value
and just say that it reinforces
the connection
between CO2 in the atmosphere
and global temperature.
Now I want to talk about other
kinds of sediments.
On land, you can walk around
and see rocks like this.
I'm sure you have. Rocks
that seem to
have a layered structure.
Most of the time, when you see
such rock patterns, you're
looking at some kind
of evidence of
ancient climate change.
One kind of climate allowed
sediments in a lake
to look like this.
A change in climate changed
it to that.
A change back gave sediments
like this.
This is easy to speculate about,
because you see lots of
sedimentary layered
rocks like that.
It's not so easy to figure out
what exactly this means in
terms of climate.
But it's a start to be able to
see such stratification on
land and just imagine in a
vague way, this may be
evidence of changing climates
in the ancient world.
How many have been to
the Grand Canyon?
You see something like this.
And lots of layered rocks.
And what you should be thinking
of when you see rocks
like this is ancient
climate change.
These changes probably are
telling us something about
changes in the ancient
climate of the Earth.
But again, they're rather
difficult to sort out, because
we don't always know the
environment in which those
sediments were laid down.
So we're going to do something
similar to this but in the
ocean, where the ocean sediments
have had a rather
constant sedimentation rate.
And therefore, we can do
a little easier job of
interpreting if we can
get a sample of that.
So the way we do that is to
do deep ocean drilling.
You take a ship that has
a drilling rig on it.
And you lower that drill bit
down to the ocean floor and
then start pushing into
the soft sediments.
And then after a while as you
go deeper and deeper, you're
drilling into rather solid
rock, but it's all
representing deep
ocean sediments.
And they look like this.
They're about the same size.
But they're made of rock.
And here's an archive of
hundreds and thousands of such
deep sea cores that have been
drilled out and stored.
So we have a lot of
these samples.
We can do a lot of
work with them.
And primarily these deep sea
sediments are comprised of
calcium carbonate.
They've got other things in
them, but calcium carbonate,
CaCO3, it has oxygen in it.
Besides calcium and carbon,
it has oxygen in it.
And they're mostly the remains
of shells produced by
microorganisms, phytoplankton
mostly, in the ocean.
And when the organism makes its
shell, it gets its oxygen
from the oxygen in water.
So there stored in this calcium
carbonate is a record
of the isotope ratio
of oxygen--
O-18 to O-16 in ocean water,
because the organism got its
oxygen from seawater in order
to make that shell.
I'm going to show you a deep sea
sediment core, RC13-259,
the one right there.
Here is Antarctica, Cape Horn,
Cape of Good Hope, Australia,
New Zealand.
And the deep sea sediment core
in the ocean is here.
And we're going to compare that
with the Vostok Ice Core,
which is there.
So what we've done is take
samples of the oxygen from the
calcium carbonate.
We expect that sample of oxygen
is going to be slightly
heavier isotopically than the
ocean water, because when the
organism makes its shell,
it slightly
prefers the heavier isotope.
In addition to that, though,
we expect it to change with
climate either because the
temperature effect on how the
organism makes its shell might
be coming through, or the
isotope ratio in the water
itself might be
dominating the signal.
The first papers on this
thought it was this.
Now there's an almost universal
agreement in the
scientific literature that when
you get oxygen 18 data
from ice cores, you're mostly
getting a measure of the
oxygen in the ocean water, and
that's telling you something
about the glacial ice mass, how
much water has been stored
up on land in the glaciers.
So most of the literature now is
purporting this idea, that
it's most sensitive to
continental ice mass.
That means it's going to be
heavy during an ice age.
Let me explain that
with a cartoon.
In a period like today, an
interglacial period, the
oceans are full of water.
This is our reference state
today by the way for O-18.
During a glacial period, you
have lowered sea level by
evaporating water from the ocean
and not returning it.
Remember the Quinnipiac
field trip, right?
You're evaporating water
from the ocean.
You're raining it out over land,
and it's running right
back into the oceans
in rivers.
No net change.
The hydrologic cycle is just
running in steady state.
The oceans are staying at the
same level and so on.
However, during a glacial
period, you've evaporated some
of that water and
not returned it.
You stored it as a large sheet
on the continents.
We know that that water is
lighter isotopically than the
ocean, so you stored light water
on the continents, which
means that the oceans are now
isotopically heavier than they
were before.
And that's the signal we hope
to see in the deep sea
sediment cores.
So here's the comparison.
Vostok delta D is plotted in the
upper panel, and the scale
is on the left.
This deep sea sediment core,
which is represented as delta
O-18, is plotted on the right.
And it's the lower panel.
And the time scales
are matched up.
So we can go back 400,000 years
into the past for both
of these records.
And notice how they line up.
But the signals are opposite.
So during an ice age, the delta
D is more negative,
whereas the deep sea sediment
core is more positive, because
you've stored light water on
land, made the oceans heavier,
and that signal is
coming through.
So you see, this is perhaps even
more remarkable, because
we have two very different kinds
of records, a deep sea
sediment core and an ice core,
whose isotopic signals are
driven by somewhat different
physics, and yet they both
give us a corresponding similar
record of the advance
and retreat of these ice ages.
It's a rather remarkable
result.
That's why these isotopes are
so valuable in giving us a
quantitative understanding of
the Pleistocene Period.
Any questions on that?
So you'll have to think about
this, because I know it's a
complicated subject, but
these notes are posted.
So part of the story then and
this is not a surprise if you
put all that ice up
on land, you will
have lowered sea level.
And so here is a record from
physical measurements, going
around various places,
understanding from the nature
of the shoreline where sea level
was at various times in
the past. This is thousands
of years ago.
And at the last glacial maximum,
which is here, sea
level was about 120 meters
below where it is today.
And you find that same thing no
matter where you measure.
Remember, sea level
tends to be level.
It's in the very name.
And so when you drop sea level,
you drop it the same
everywhere in the ocean.
And therefore you should get
the same record no matter
where you do that analysis.
And then as we came out of the
last ice age, we came up to
the present sea level rise.
So this is from physical
measurement, not from isotope
measurements, but it agrees
conceptually with that deep
sea sediment core analysis,
which I argued is a measure of
how much water is stored on the
land in large ice sheets,
especially the Laurentide
ice sheet and the
Fennoscandian ice sheet.
So if you made a map of the
Earth during the last glacial
maximum, land would be
somewhat larger.
Of course we know this is mostly
continental shelf.
You don't have to lower the
ocean very much in order to
expand it out a bit--expand the
continents out, because
there's some shallow submerged
land today.
But that's typically where the
coastline would have been
15,000 to 20,000 years ago.
And the point I want to make
here is that the gap between
Asia and North America was
actually bridged at that time
because of a lowered
sea level.
It's believed then that this
was the moment when humans
could first migrate
to North America.
And so this business of sea
level change and ice ages then
directly carries over to the
anthropology of the Americas.
When did people first come to
this continent, and how did
they get there?
And there are other theories.
They may have sailed
from Asia.
They may have sailed from the
islands in the Pacific.
But this, I believe, is still
the leading theory for how
humans, which evolved in Africa
and Asia, finally made
it to the New World.
And they did that about 20,000
years ago following the Bering
Sea Land Bridge.
The way anthropologists, or
archaeologists describe the
different cultures in the
Americas is by the type of
arrowheads that they made.
So the Clovis culture sorry
about that would have made the
Clovis points.
They can track this back to
about 11,500 years, but before
that, there's not too much
record of humans, which means
probably that's about
when they came.
So roughly during the period of
the last glacial maximum is
probably when these cultures
moved to the New World.
And all the Indian cultures we
see today then in the desert
southwest or up in the northwest
US and Canada, those
cultures probably came
over about that time.
There is a national park up on
the northwest coast of Alaska.
I want to go there someday.
It's called the Land
Bridge Preserve.
And on their website, they show
human footprints, which
supposedly are a record of those
people walking It must
have been cold though, but I
guess they had built up a
resistance to the cold over
from Asia to North America
during that period of time.
I only have a couple minutes
to talk about
Milankovitch theory.
Your book does a pretty good
job of it, but I do want to
spend a couple minutes on it.
What has caused this periodic
coming and going of the ice
sheets during the Pleistocene?
It's not a solved problem.
I don't want to present this
to you as known fact, but
there is considerable evidence
that slow changes in the
Earth's orbit induced by Jupiter
and other planets
probably were what caused or at
least in some way paced the
coming and going of the ice ages
during the Pleistocene.
And the three changes in the
orbital parameters that are
discussed--that are understood
in this regard are the
precession that is a slow
rotation of the orientation of
the Earth's tilt.
Second is the obliquity, which
is the magnitude of the
Earth's tilt.
And the third is the
eccentricity
of the Earth's orbit.
You know that the Earth's orbit
around the sun is not
exactly circular.
It has a little bit of
eccentricity to it.
And the amount of that
eccentricity has been changing
slowly with time.
The precession goes through a
full cycle all the way around
and back in about
20,000 years.
The obliquity, this little
changing of the tilt, goes
through a full cycle
approximately
every 40,000 years.
And the eccentricity, the
changing of the ellipticity of
this orbit, goes through
a cycle of about
every 100,000 years.
This is the smallest effect.
And recent papers suggest
that this may not be
playing much of a role.
Most of the attention the last
few years has been on these
two cycles for causing these
advances and retreats.
What these things mostly do, if
you think about it, is that
they change the way
seasonality works.
Remember, the obliquity, the
tilt of the Earth's axis,
controls seasonality on Earth.
And the precession, the way that
this orientation of the
tilt lines up with the long axis
of the orbit, controls
the strength of the seasons also
because of the way the
tilt and the perihelion
combine.
So these two things are mostly
changing the seasonality, but
apparently that is enough
to push us into and
out of an ice age.
This diagram shows the same
thing in different order, the
eccentricity, the obliquity,
and the precession.
And I think that's all I have
to talk about today.
Yeah.
So we got just through
this at the end.
I think you have enough to
finish up that problem set.
And on Friday we'll begin
to work on the
subject of global warming.
Read chapter 13.
Chapter 13 is your key in
the book.